long cues of desperate people in
Acapulco
Mexico we need food and water they
brought water but look how many of us
there are there are so many of
us more than 1,600 people have been
displaced after Hurricane Otis slammed
into the resort Town last
week frustrated residents expressed
anger over the government
response where is the government's
support look at the queue they tell us
that water will be delivered at 8:00
a.m. and we've been here since 5:00 a.m.
we're risking being mugged the owner of
this Funeral Home says that with no
electricity it's become nearly
impossible to provide services to the
families of storm
victims as there is no electricity we
are not preparing the buddies and we
don't have permission to bury them we
have to wait two or three days Mexico's
president promises to get Acapulco back
on its feet and has deployed some 18,000
members of Mexico's Armed Forces to
assist with cleanup and restoration the
search for the missing goes on Manuel
rapalo Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer